[Music]  emilia clarke channels daenerys  targaryen IRL  [Music]  the mother of dragons has officially  gone a Khaleesi shade of platinum I take  what is mine on Tuesday she took to  Instagram with this cheeky photo  debuting her new icy blonde Bob which  makes her look just like her regal Game  of Thrones character riccati  as for Amelia's caption I I done did it  the actress continued with an  introduction writing mother of dragons  meet Amelia Amelia meet mother of  dragons if you squint just so you might  never know and she hailed to the  magnificence of the genius creators who  are responsible for both the Khaleesi  wig and her new wintry look thanking  them for at long last making this  magical moment a reality is it done then  they belong to me now Amelia will give  off some serious mother of dragons Ives  wherever she goes  [Music]  you